there's something online called mukbang
videos oh did you show me one of these I
don't [__] get it at
all I don't feel good about this because
I if you are a gung-ho to show me a
video I feel like I'm not going to like
it oh I know for a fact you're not going
to like it I don't want this to trigger
you because I know it makes you angry
like Angry the sound of people eating oh
I hate that that's what I'm saying but
like I I wish an asmer
would you say have asmer asmer ASMR yeah
asmer isn't that called asmer it's
called
[Laughter]
ASMR I thought it was called asmer it's
an abbreviation for What audio
stimulated something hold on I'll Google
it but ASMR stands for something for
sure oh I thought it was just called
asmer
ASM
assm stop yo dude if they called it as
Mister there'd be a lot of people
clicking on there without knowing what
it is is as mister and mukbang the same
thing yeah like so mukbang entails like
uh mukbang videos also are like some
like weird I don't know Kink things for
people because they like to watch people
eat but also for some people it's like
they're craving a certain food they
can't eat it so they watch other people
eat it and it satisfies that need for
them to want which is the which is the
opposite for me because it would just
make me want the food more yeah but also
some people think like the sound of the
crunch is coming or like like that ASMR
stands for autonomous sensory Meridian
response a term used for to describe a
tingling static like or Goosebump
sensation in response to specific
triggering audio or visual stimuli I
think as Mister is way better as Mister
is pretty
fun but like I don't want to [__] up
your mood no let's do it it's not going
to [__] up my mood let's do it it made
you so angry last time I showed you that
you're using the word angry you said you
said then and there that it made you
angry it just bothers me
angry you said quote that made me angry
I might need to go smoke some weed it
Angry is not the right word it [__]
definitely I don't like the noises I
think I saw Chelsea Lynn do a mukbang
with her husband oh when they're eating
the McDonald's in the car yeah yeah yeah
but she my favorite line from that she
has one of my favorite lines ever in
that do you know what it is and she took
a bite of a pancake and she goes I just
made my [__] throb oh my God is so
funny yeah yeah yeah yeah she but she
but she's funny yeah no this is all
serious so like these people don't say
anything during they just drink and eat
that's it how the [__] does that have 15
million views and is a asmer mukbang
where does mukbang come from um I think
from when I looked it up it comes from
uh it comes from uh a Korean it's
derived from like a Korean culture but I
don't remember what it stands for um but
it's a Korean it's a Korean word like
the actual word is mukbang and this dude
has 15 million views on this oh dude
this is going to be loud I can't
wait I don't mind that noise at
all why is he wearing gloves to not get
his hands greasy I don't know he's also
just he's handling a lot of different
foods can I tell you that the black
gloves might bother me more than
whatever noise is about to come out
really why is he wearing black gloves to
eat I don't know that I don't know why
that bothers me but boy it does
okay I mean this is fine he's just
showing you what he's going to eat hey
why don't we get to the middle so we to
get to the eating part yeah yeah maybe
we'll skip a littleit we's just see when
he starts eating that's what I want to
do oh [__]
you
what the
[__] what the [__] people just sit and
watch this why 15 million what the [__]
fuk is
this it's just him eating chicken
nuggets does he eat all of that yeah he
eats all of it or at least tries a bit
of all of it
oh this I want to hear the onion ring I
want to hear the onion
ring
oh yeah it's pretty good
A he's so sweaty
yeah you okay all right you can pause it
that's that that's enough torture for
him why is he
sweaty keep going no well let's go to
that part you want to go to the end no
no no right there it's good this part oh
that oh wait wait it gets
better oh he didn't even
what him chewing in my ear right now
makes me want to run through that
[__]
wall there's people who also do like
Ramen eating videos so it's just them
slurping Ramen the entire time I would
probably choke
myself why are his fries stacked like
that okay I'm not all right he's good
he's good why why are his fries stacked
like that I just noticed cuz he's a
[__] psycho that's why yeah that is
weird who Stacks fries like that
dude that dude needs some Lincoln
Logs that was terrible that was amazing
yeah so that's what we call mukbang well
you know there are videos where they
have hot girls doing that yeah yeah and
it's like a fetish thing let me see if
it's any better find hot girl eating
sandwich let me see if that makes it any
better I can't imagine that it would
this dude at Mr asmer hold on before
don't go anywhere don't go anywhere on
off this page 15 million
views it was
posted 15 n months ago million views he
has 24 million subscribers
correct what the ficky fuk he's got 24
and all he does is eat can you go to his
videos Zach Choy ass
mister is it all eating
uh it's all ASMR so it might be like
other things but it looks like all
eating best of Zack
Choy what hold on that only has 87,000
views oh that's two days ago this is the
latest yo this dude does it every day 86
million views hit me hit me with that I
mean what am I doing with my life maybe
I should just go home and eat some
celery record it post it I am record it
and post it 100% I'm going I'm going to
make I'm gonna what is that will you
unmute it for us Matt oh it's unmuted JK
today we're
doing let's let's cut to it yeah let's
get to the eating I don't need to hear
them
oneing oh that one's intense the
macaroon is
[Laughter]
intense and she laughed when you did
that it's almost like she heard you you
that was
amazing it took us over three hours to
make oh that one was
crazy done yeah that's
enough yeah that one was
crazy I'm going to go home and eat some
celery do it post it and we'll see post
it how how many how many many views do
you think my celery video will
get 20K you post it on YouTube or on
just on Instagram
YouTube I'm gonna I'm going to start a
Josh Wolf mukbang Channel let's do
it oh my God it's the only way to get
over one thing you hate is to conquer it
just start making the videos here's what
I want to hear from you if anybody is a
mukbanger why because there's 24 million
ion views that means somebody who's
listening to this or watching this is a
mukbanger by the way it sounds dirty but
it isn't what exactly what if you are an
ass mister or a mukbanger ass mister now
I will tell you something about the ass
mister the unwrapping of stuff yeah I
don't mind that the crinkling noises I
get it and she's an attractive woman
that did not make it any better M no it
doesn't make it any better but it's
actually makes it worse of
some but this dude I'm really curious
what he looks like
neck down do you think he's because he
looks pretty thin for eating can I be
honest with you most of the mukbang
people are thin most of them are skinny
people and do you think he's listening
to himself eat maybe but also he's
probably wearing the headphones because
the headphones have a microphone that's
close to his mouth so that's what he's
like that's what's picking up this high
intensity and then obviously he Post in
post he brings up the volume
heavy H how do you decide that's what
you're going to do these look like
regular people yeah yeah what's the
what's the green thing you think aloe
they ate aloe or probably played with it
because it's like really like sticky and
makes sounds and do I want to see
that no please send my dad more mukbang
videos I'm a little
shook not just by what I heard but by
the immense popularity
I get the a the assm more than I get
watching people
eat food because when I see somebody eat
it BS you yeah but but if I saw somebody
eating an In-N-Out Burger I'd be like
man I want In-N-Out yeah yeah yeah but I
will tell you watching him eat all that
made me never want to eat anything ever
again yeah yeah yeah I think I'm going
to start sending you videos of me eating
things just on a on an every now and
then to [__] you up I'm not gonna lie to
you part of me wants to I might have to
message Zach Choy directly and just be
like why you ruined two days for me I
just want you to know
that oh yeah hey man hey
[Music]
man oh yeah hey man hey
man